[Music]
today we have the exciting opportunity
to cancel a pet food company the better
choice company makes super premium
natural pet food for millennial and gen
z pet parents
now we've already have enough fodder
here just in the opening sentence to
cancel everybody in sight but it gets
better as yahoo finance reports the very
unaptly named better choice company has
launched a new ad campaign for its halo
dog food brand and here's the marketing
pitch according to yahoo it says quote
let's face it pets are the world's best
kids that's why better choice company a
pet health and wellness company unveils
its new marketing campaign to celebrate
pet parenthood
the new halo pet campaign sets out to
validate and empower the new generation
of pet moms the campaign launches in
support of the company's new brand halo
elevate a super premium natural pet food
backed by science millennials are
delaying having children they are
however enthusiastically embracing pet
parenthood with 76 of millennials owning
a pet the new campaign from halo is
speaking to these pet moms and saying
we see you we get you we are you
now if i was a narcissist
i might think this ad campaign was made
specifically to annoy me personally
because it's got all of the elements
there
and those suspicions are not much
allayed by the actual ad itself which we
will watch now
halo makes the world's best food for the
world's best kids no not that kid this
kid you can leave this kid alone for 10
minutes and they won't destroy your
house yeah with these kids you can
actually sleep in
and shopping never ends in tears
maybe being a human parent is overrated
so if you're gonna have a kid make it a
furry one and feed them halo elevate
natural science-based nutrition for
their optimal health halo the world's
best food for the world's best kids
okay
where to begin i i don't deny that
having kids is actually more difficult
than having a dog and we'll get to that
in a moment but first of all
dogs don't destroy your house or wake
you up
what
i find it a bit concerning that nobody
this dog food company has ever actually
met a dog apparently in fact dogs tend
to be way more destructive than children
they also can significa be significantly
noisier and more annoying
my kids have never eaten my boots or nod
on the legs of my couch or chewed on the
carpet
my kids don't eat out of the trash
my kids don't poop on the floor usually
my kids don't wake me up in the middle
of the night barking
i don't have to take my kids outside of
the dead of winter and stand there
waiting for them to take a dump in the
grass
none of my kids have ever vomited on the
kitchen tile and then tried to eat it
dog has done that though multiple times
i came home a few days ago and um
someone in the house had torn into my
bookshelf and eaten two of my favorite
books
guess who did that wasn't my kids i can
tell you
now i'm starting to wonder actually what
kind of kids these people have
encountered
you know what my kids can do they can
clean up after themselves okay sure it
does take a lot of coaching and often i
have to
you know deploy various methods of
encouragement shall we say to get them
to clean up but
you can actually raise your kids to
clean up after themselves a dog will
never do that if a dog like picks up a
shoe in his mouth and walks it over to
the other side of the room right and
drops it there everybody will applaud oh
look at the dog he's so great it would
take the dog about 19 hours to clean a
whole room at that pace
my kids can do it in at least 18 hours
my kids can do other things too like
they can pour their own bowls of cereal
in the morning they can bathe themselves
in fact
they can do literally thousands of
things that the dog cannot do and will
never be able to do and as my kids get
older they'll become even more
self-sufficient while my dog will still
be barking at leaves and crapping all
over the place
but here's the main difference between
my children and the dog
they are my children
the dog is not my child he's a dog
i'm not the parent of my dog and you are
not the parent of your dog
so stop saying that you are
you are not a dog mommy do you know who
your dog's mommy is another dog
there's a dog that mated with another
dog and had a dog and that dog gave
birth to your dog
and that dog is your dog's mommy
you didn't mate with a dog and have a
dog i sure hope you didn't
okay not only are you not your pet's
parent but in fact your relationship
with
with and to your pet bears no
resemblance at all to the relationship a
parent has with into their actual human
child
aside from all the many functional
differences between dogs and kids the
other major difference is that within a
human nuclear family
there's an opportunity for a loving bond
which far surpasses anything you will
ever experience with any other human
much less a mangy four-legged beast
i love my kids in a way that i could
never love an animal
i know them in a way that i could never
know an animal i was there with them
when they were born i've i've cared for
them every moment of their lives i've
gotten to know them more deeply as time
has gone on we can talk and have
conversations we can share experiences
on a much deeper and more meaningful
level then you can share any experience
with a dog
my children have brought me great joy
they they uh more joy than any animal
can bring they also can make me much
angrier and more frustrated than any
animal can make me but that's only
because
they are human beings they are complex
they can be
rebellious and strong-willed they're
self-aware they have their own ideas
about the world
my dog has no ideas about anything
he's an idiot and always will be
it is much more complicated to
discipline a child right
and there's more at stake
so if you fail as a parent your child
might become a monster who inflicts
unimaginable suffering on himself and
the world if you fail as a dog owner
your dog might bite the mailman or
whatever
does this mean that it's it's better to
own dogs because it's easier no
it means that owning dogs is simpler and
easier in some respects but also much
less important
there's much less potential for
greatness and for love in its fullest
and deepest form just as you you know
you could you could climb a mountain
or you could sit on your butt and watch
tv a lot less can go wrong watching tv
it's easier and takes less effort does
that mean it's better to watch tv does
that mean that you should never climb
any mountains whether literally or
metaphorically
sure if you want to live a shallow and
meaningless life
but here's the thing if you avoid the
difficult things in life
you also are avoiding the greatest joys
and most fulfilling and most meaningful
experiences that life has to offer this
is the bargain you make when you elect
to be a dog parent quote unquote instead
of a real parent
and if your goal is just to be
comfortable and live with ease then why
not get an ant farm instead of a dog why
not stick with a goldfish or a pet rock
because the further you go down the
intelligence and self-awareness ladder
the easier it is to be a parent quote
unquote of those kinds of creatures
there's also far less potential again
for love for joy for purpose for meaning
and lord when it willing my kids will
grow older
and long after my dog dies my kids will
start having kids of their own and their
kids will have kids and eventually i
will die and as i'm laying on my death
bed i will know and take comfort in the
fact that my children are alive they'll
be there for me in my final days just as
i was there in their
first days
i'm not going to be thinking about my
dead dog in those moments this dog i
have now will have been replaced five or
six times over by then but my legacy
will live on in my children and in
theirs
my blood will run through their veins
we'll be connected forever in this life
and the next that's parenthood
not pet ownership
now this perhaps has gotten a little too
serious for a conversation that began
with a dog food commercial but as you
may have noticed there are a few things
i hate more than when people act as
though pets are equivalent to children
they are not
and that is why the better choice dog
food company
is today cancelled
well before you go uh hit the subscribe
button and ring the bell and while
you're at it if you want to go watch or
listen to my full show head to
dailywire.com and subscribe you can also
catch my show on spotify apple podcast
or wherever you get your podcast so go
check it out now i demand it
your compliance is somewhat appreciated
you